and the formula that we want to use is
this one right over here it's n minus
two times 180 equals the sum of the
interior angles so all the inner angles
added up okay that's going to be that
total there so here you can see we've
got five angles or five sides either one
five minus two times 180 equals what
well that's three times 180 which equals
540 all these angles have to add up to
540 so let's make an equation 91 plus
120 plus X plus 80 plus 93 has to add up
to that 540 so all we need to do now is
solve for X and we've got it so let's go
to the calculator 91 plus 120 plus 80
plus 93 that comes out to 384 so we have
X plus 384 equals 540 just subtract the
384 from both sides right and we've got
it so 540 - looks like a hundred and
fifty-six degrees so that's the measure
of that missing interior angle this one
right here okay so the example number
two says find the interior angle in a
regular 14 gone so what does it mean
when they say regular it means all the
angles are the same okay and all the
sides are the same length as well but if
it's a fourteen guy that means it has
fourteen sides or fourteen angles so
what we're going to do is we're going to
do this a couple different ways we're
going to do n minus two times 180 okay
in this case it's 14 so I'm going to put
14 right there so we've got 12 14 minus
2 is 12 times 180 that's going to give
us the sum of all the interior angles so
if we do that we'll go to the calculator
here 12 times 180 that gives us 2160 but
we just want to find the measure of one
angle so we're going to divide by 14
since there's 14 of them right okay so
that was pretty easy it's about a
hundred and fifty four point three
degrees the other way to do this problem
is you can use the formula 360 divided
by N or divided by 14 this will give you
the measure of the exterior angle okay
because all the exterior angles always
add up to 360 in a polygon like this so
basically the exterior
coming out to 25.7 and one thing you'll
notice about these two angles is that
they're supplementary they add up to 180
degrees so I don't actually know how to
draw a 14 guy okay but let's just
pretend like it looks something like
this okay if you extend one of those
sides
that's your exterior angle right there
25.7 but your interior angle c100 54.3
these are going to form a straight line
they're going to be supplementary
they're a linear pair so you can either
use the formula 360 divided by n to get
the exterior angle or you can use this
formula n minus 2 times 180 equals the
sum of the interior angles but then
you're going to have to divide it by how
many angles that you have to find the
measure of just one of the angles so I
hope this helps you to understand how to
work with you know finding that missing
interior angle better subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring and I look forward to
helping in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon